لديك جناح
كبير
هنا في إكسبو ، لماذا هذا
أنت تعرف أولاً وقبل كل شيء أن يكون لديك هذا
الجناح أه لشركة طيران الإمارات ،
فهو يعرض ما
كنا نقوم به
فيما
يتعلق بالخدمة التي نقدمها أولاً وقبل كل شيء
لعملائنا
وأيضًا  للنظر في مستقبل دبي
للطيران وهذا سوف
يشرح كل
شيء هل ما زلت متحمسًا للطيران
أفعل كل الوقت الذي تعرفه لأن
هناك الكثير مما يمكنك فعله أعتقد أن
النظر إلى هذا الواقع الافتراضي هذه
تجربة  الكثير من الناس
للتفاعل ومعرفة المنتج الذي
سنحصل عليه في المستقبل إذا كان بإمكانك
إجراء تغيير واحد ، ما
الذي ستعرفه ، أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا دائمًا النظر
إلى المستقبل
بعيون مفتوحة ونقول حسنًا.
سأفعل ذلك وأعطيه أيضًا
وقتًا كافيًا لدراسته